we got a lot of gifts here grip on this  I can't get a grip  it's a golf blanket It's gotta be the  lamest gift I've ever seen  you get  it's a book that says cooking with semen  how is that real guys how could I forget  the penis shaped  dark glittery charcuterie board it's a  gag ball  he shows it  stroke drainer oh holy [ __ ] they got me  one of the Trump nfts no they did it  dude you put this in your ass what do  you do with this what the hell is that  the ultimate ball holder is put your  nuts in it I guess so for what reason  this is the best Christmas ever we got a  bunch of good [ __ ] semen cookbook  cocaine uh stroke trainer lobsters that  we were able to rip in half yeah  guilt-free